hey everybody i'm danny director welcome
to a very special LIVE edition of daily
denny
i told you guys yesterday this season of
America's Got Talent has been so lit and
that's why these two are here because I
crushed the audition
please welcome us the deal us the duo
you guys thank you so much for coming
hang out with that thanks for having a
GT the season season has been amazing
I've been explained to these guys if
you're not watching you need to you guys
are out no exception that audition was
so cute and so memorable I'm still that
song and still kind of playing in my
head now that it's been out in the world
for a couple weeks how does it feel
I mean how has life changed for you guys
well it feels amazing it's just so cool
because this is the biggest stage we've
ever played on and we've played in front
of all these eyes all over the US and to
get the support that we've gotten so far
has just been so exciting and it's so
it's our you know wedding song totally I
believe that I was gonna say cuz you
know that's such a personal song to you
but then you're performing it well what
was amazing was at the beginning of your
guys's audition you said we have a dream
of starting a family it's pretty awesome
how are you feeling about this next
chapter I'm excited honestly I'm just
excited to be a dad yeah I don't know
what I'm doing at all but you know she's
it since the day we met she said I just
want to have a child with you and I said
just give us some time let's work on a
little bit and to see how happy she gets
to know that she's pregnant and everyday
she just rubs in she's like this is the
best ever
I know makes her so happy and I'm just
excited it's a good time away that's
awesome I know I saw you guys were
working on the nursery you mentioned you
have so much energy so it's just like a
really really good time everything's
going well very well yeah what are you
most looking forward to about motherhood
about being a father I think just it's
just such a cool opportunity that we get
to teach a child how did how to be how
to act how to love and we just want to
do our best at teaching them how to love
everyone and it kind
oh my gosh we need more parents like you
guys to mold these young people leave
your other babies your fur babies were
what's going on look at look at Billie
Jean the what if she's like side I like
they're like much more cuddly now it's
so sweet
I've heard that happens the sense that
you you're carrying a child or something
they're just like resting next to the
belly and stuff that's really cute guys
I forgot to mention if you have any
questions for us the duo I know a lot of
fans out there watching centum we'll get
right to this iPad but yeah you guys so
you know you auditioned for a GT did you
know you were pregnant at that moment I
don't think we quite know yet
it was taped we didn't know I don't
think yeah you know it was an idea in
her head that we wanted to happen yes we
were practicing that was your dream and
then not only did you make it to the
next you guys perform the original song
no matter where you are which was an
extension of your marriage vows why was
import for you to choose or to sing that
song for your audition honestly I think
it's just the most comfortable song for
us we've seen it so many times since we
got married and we love it and I just
think it spreads a good message you know
no matter we're all I'll be there it
could be about your family member it
could be about your significant other it
could be about anything really and it
just spreads a good message and we
wanted to make sure we did that while we
were on stage does the novelty wear off
at all you mentioned you guys sing you
know why yeah it's like revisiting your
vows it can be sweet but I mean be
honest you get tired of it you know
actually on the contrary I like it
because you know when you go to a
wedding and you watch people get married
it and it like reinvigorates your love
so every time we sing it it just reminds
me why is she so special to me so as as
cheesy as that sounds it's just a good
reminder to me that she's my wife and
I'm with her for the rest of my life and
it makes me happy so we sing it and also
I do feel comfortable singing the song
so many times so in a situation like AGT
where you have judges in your on camera
which I'm not used to it just takes away
some of the nerves
to mention the fact that you guys are
performing multiple instruments as well
you know there's a lot going on in
Norway so I'm sure it's like second
nature we are singing a song like that
right what do you guys nailed it is so
beautiful it's also the song that got
you working with Oprah right because was
in the movie the book of life as she saw
it I mean is there anything you learned
for it cuz she took you on tour first of
all that was awesome guys Oprah dust ya
know was with the authors and
inspirational speakers right I mean is
there anything you learned from that
experience and working with Oprah that
you maybe still carry with you
especially on this next journey yeah
she's a queen she actually put a note in
her calendar that said the day I hugged
my journal when I met Oprah it was very
brief but I'll never forget oh my gosh
no I I remember she surprised us while
we were performing on stage she came
behind us and knew you like and juggs us
and she says you guys sound amazing and
I'm like oh my gosh Oprah she's hugging
me she smells good
her hair is nice and poufy and I just
want to continue to hug her forever but
ya know she's just such an inspiration
and and she's lived out her dream she
had an vision for herself when she was
younger and then she went and got it she
worked so it's just an inspiration to us
to just never give up on what our dreams
are and as we grow our family to just
never lose sight of that absolutely do
you guys keep in touch with Oprah we
haven't talked in a while only bring it
up because I hear she gives really good
gifts for baby showers I was just saying
I think I think you need the book club
collection you know so Oprah if you're
watching they're pregnant they can use
some things so you know you guys have
been doing your things and fine on
YouTube and now AGT working with Oprah
how does this experience stack up you
know working or excuse me auditioning
for people like Simon Cowell and Mel B
and Howie Mandel this is uh pretty
surreal because we watch the show every
year which is a big big reason why we
actually went on the show cuz we're fans
and we know how the platform works and
so when we got up there there was a
moment of
oh my gosh this is reality because you
sit on your couch and you watch the show
and you think this is an amazing show
but when you actually step on the stage
in Simon Cowell is within you know 50
feet of you the nerve set in and you
know this is really cool so I think as
far as ranking it with other things
we've done it's definitely up at the top
and a big part of that is because we're
learning so much about our music and how
to carry ourselves in really stressful
situations so I like to be challenged
and that's exactly what America's Got
Talent is doing for me in us right how
are you guys preparing for that next
round or how did you prepare for that
next round yeah we really wanted to
stick to our originals I know a Simon
was a fan of the original and we really
trust his opinion because he works in
music and we think he knows what he's
doing um so we were kind of going back
and forth with do we do something that
will resonate with people because they
know it like a cover or do we just stick
to what we love to do and it's original
so I we're working on more of those make
sure the baby's inspiring some new stuff
to write music is your life and this is
a big part of your life right now so I
could only imagine this stuff that's
cooking I can do that let's take some
fan questions are coming in uh Moe is
saying are there any songs in particular
you're excited to play on toward the
together tour this summer are there any
songs in particular you guys are really
excited at perform live again for the
fans yes I mean I always love performing
in front of the fans and and seeing how
they react to our songs but one of the
songs I'm most excited to sing is
together it's a single we put out and I
just love it because we we sang it after
a gender-reveal and it was really
special and emotional and Michael
started crying
midway so you can watch the live as well
but it was just so special and I think
it's a great song again for anyone
friends and family too so what about you
the same for me because we get to sing
it's kind of about our future child so
we get to sing that and while she has
this big bump on stage I feel like
there's gonna be a lot of emotions
happening at that time so I don't know I
hope you do well through the whole
did you guys were you hoping for a girl
yes
Nicolette from Facebook is asking if you
were to sing a different song for your
audition what would it have been a good
question I mean did you guys have songs
lined up that you were you know debating
about singing and performing yeah we did
we had a few options we were toying
around with but that was the song we
really wanted to play mainly because
we're so comfortable with it but also
because it's who we are no matter where
you are so the fact that that did happen
made me very happy but I don't know what
else we would have probably another
original yeah and maybe something that's
not released yet yeah there's still time
yeah however those unreleased there's
more you know the reason why you started
with this tea from YouTube so what got
you guys the courage to go on stage and
to audition for AGT Wow
well the courage for me it came from her
because I almost had a mini panic attack
backstage
I don't really do well in in like very
extroverted situation so she carries a
lot of that way and you know I love
performing on stage and hiding behind my
instrument but when I have to just hold
a microphone my hands start shaking
because I rely on this or this and also
when there's four people staring at you
as you play with a big buzzer they have
the power and that just got in my head
so we were a side stage and I was
shaking and I was like if I can do this
and she said Michael collect yourself we
can do this together
I'm here with you and she said let me
take the talking on the interview and
when she said that all of my stress went
away and if you watch the audition on TV
you saw that she predominantly talked
and that's because I couldn't and she
helped and I'm just so thankful for you
that's so sweet
I mean honestly you guys are so lucky to
have each other that to go through stuff
like this cuz it is really intense
there's a lot of factors at play I mean
what has it meant to each other to share
this journey both in both personally and
professionally yeah I mean
think we are very blessed to be able to
do this together you're right because
when I have those moments of nerves and
anxiety I look at him I'm like oh I'm
not alone I have him to share this with
I have him to make these memories with
and travel the world with it's so
special I don't have to call home and be
like hey babe
I had a great show today you know
because he was there you got to share it
with me so we're very lucky yeah you
guys are each other's rocks your
relationship goals do people tell you
that cuz I get that vibe
in fact Megan from facebook says Michael
you are the cutest I love how much you
love Carissa it's funny versa too you
guys sent it right I love that um so
obviously there's a lot going on how are
you guys finding that balance you know
with your careers and also preparing for
a baby man it's it's a lot of
communication yeah for sure when she's
feeling something she just has to tell
me and vice-versa whether we're side
stage and we're arguing or whether she's
tired especially with the baby now and
now we're going on tour and you know
she's just got to communicate that to me
I need a break or let's shut down the
meet-and-greet for now or let's delay
she'll 15 minutes so I can gather myself
and figure out what's going on here she
lets me know that and same with me to
her you know if I'm feeling extra
anxious that day or my voice isn't
tip-top shape she carries the load of
the singing so it's all about just
communicating whatever we're feeling and
it usually works out yeah that's really
the secret right yeah there is this
communication definitely I'm balancing
it out too I think we've learned over
the years of being a duo and working
together while also being in
relationship it's it's a very fine
balance and making sure we make time for
each other in a relationship and putting
that first always and then and then
comes the music and our job but knowing
your guys's work ethic something tells
me those moments are fleeting though
that were like in fact let's get another
one in here let's see um Nicolette I
already did that one Colton for Facebook
how long did it take you to complete
your marriage vows oh my god you guys
are songwriters so something tells me
that King kind of quickly but don't you
tell me yeah I feel ya cuz when we
started writing our vows that's the
music just kind of came out of it and
that's where the song came out of and he
was like let's just perform
this has a surprise for our family and
friends at our wedding I'm like okay so
that was really nerve-wracking by the
way that was the first time we've ever
played it and the day we were getting
married yeah I think as far as our
spoken vows as well it took take about a
day do you remember that day in the
kitchen like I had written down the vows
and then I brought you the notebook and
I put out the guitar and we had those
like skylights and it was really bright
I was like let's just start playing
through our vows even a good idea just
try just see what comes out and I think
it all came together in about three
hours the whole song and it just felt
good it was fun it was fun to sing and
perform so I was like let's do it I mean
it's like I said it's just you know who
you guys are
it's second nature so inevitably I think
you guys probably start singing I'm
actually officiating my best friend's
wedding any advice I mean what do you
guys think I can't see I can't play in
this room I could probably you know find
a tutor in there but something tells me
I should probably stick to spoken word
but yeah any advice for me like who
married you guys um a friend of ours is
the best way to go because they feel the
love from you and you genuinely want
them to succeed so I think just you know
being there for them and showing as much
love as you can that's why you can't be
great at what you do but like you know
there's friends and family situation I
want one person all rap it up your butt
actually let's take a couple more here
real quick
Caitlyn from Facebook what's your a
typical date night for you guys in fact
I had that question - what's so a guy's
spend time together outside of
performing we just went on a date we did
two nights ago we loved to eat would be
one of our definite things that we do
yeah we eat and usually we have a drink
but now that's not really possible so
she just watches me drink we do that and
then we generally get dessert that's
always a must
we like to not get dessert at the
restaurant because then it becomes
another thing so
from there you know we look at each
other and say are we too tired for a
movie we are too tired for a lot of
folks want to know when the next album
is coming yeah but we have we picked
early wait do you know it I actually
don't know okay but is it it's this year
it would be within a month whoo you
heard it here first
it's the first time we this is the first
time we've ever announced anything about
it album coming within a month in a
month so we can have new music to play
on album is together together perfect of
course it is all right the last tee
everyone wants to know do you guys have
a name picked up for the baby and if so
what is it oh oh my gosh we don't but
you have a couple ideas yes my first
idea is Carissa oh my god ever been a
female junior before I'm sure that there
has to be when you're not into it I'm
not really feeling it you know I want to
give the give her own identity oh my toe
Lena no Michelle No yeah well yeah I
think we're gonna wait until she's born
to pick a name for her just so I could
see it look into her eyes and just make
sure if it's her not yet that's what
John Legend and Chrissy Teigen did right
there like they waited - the baby was
here they're like okay you are yes
that's what we love that I love that I
love you guys you really are the best
and congratulations on AGT on the baby
can't wait to see the rest of your
journey again both professionally and
personally there's a lot going on with
you guys so congrats thank you guys for
joining us and thank you for sending all
your fan questions you heard it
together new album within a month and
then they're hitting that they're going
on tour
check your website right and your
socials for those dates that kicks off
this summer are you guys went back
tomorrow with the new daily
until then make sure you're following us
on Facebook subscribing on YouTube and
that's all the plugs I got hi guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]